[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
everyone's favorite character Dolores
Umbridge as we know in the 1995 to 1996
school year the Ministry of Magic put
out a statement expressing that they
were unimpressed with the slipping
standards of Hogwarts
however in reality the standards at
Hogwarts were not slipping this
statement was purely the result of a
fearful Minister of Magic fudge lashing
out he was blinded by fear and in utter
denial that the Dark Lord Voldemort had
returned the statement suggesting
slipping standards at Hogwarts but the
result of fudge punishing Dumbledore who
was so strongly trying to convince him
of the truth long story short
Dumbledore's continual attempts to
convince fudge of this truth eventually
led to him being stripped of his title
as headmaster at Hogwarts in place of
Dumbledore the Ministry of Magic
appointed Dolores Umbridge who in that
same school year worked as the Defense
Against the Dark Arts professor as well
as the Hogwarts High Inquisitor
Dolores Umbridge is a British half-blood
witch who served as senior under
secretary to the Minister for magic
under three different ministers of magic
Cornelius fudge Rufus Scrimgeour and
pius thicknesse during her time at
Hogwarts she had enormous power of the
students teachers curriculum grounds and
basically everything she had this power
in all three of her postings and it of
course came primarily because of her
close connection to the ministry who
have a significant say in how Hogwarts
operates for the duration that she was
at Hogwarts she made the lives of the
students increasingly miserable she did
everything wrong she would conduct
unreasonable and abusive punishments as
we see in thee I will not tell lies seen
in the order of the Phoenix she would
speak to students and staff members
condescendingly and she just sucked she
definitely wasn't Hogwarts most popular
one thing that she's known for was the
implementation of educational decrees at
Hogwarts educational decrees are laws
created by the Ministry of magic which
enforce standards at the school the
introduction of educational decrees was
instigated by umbrage and it's allowed
umbrage in the ministry to begin to
expel and punish students for actions
that would have previously been fine it
gave the ministry and ambridge complete
power of everyone inside of Hogwarts it
was a total dictatorship and no one had
a voice that could contend with them
supposedly there was one other
organization involved with the
introduction of these decrees called the
very important members of section MIT Rx
this group was a board of jurists who
had the power to approve or deny
educational decrees one thing worth
noting is that there's quite a major
discrepancy between the books and films
on the master of educational decrees in
the book there are only 28 educational
agrees but the film took some liberties
with this and went a little overboard
introducing over a hundred and thirty
six decrees in total the pure volume of
these decrees nearly covering the entire
wall outside of the Great Hall hanging
up decrees definitely meant that Filch
had his work cut out for him we don't
actually know what all 136 decrees are
but here are the ones from the books and
films that we do know about most of
these decrees were only visible in the
film for a split second there's also
some crossover here and many of these
decrees are simply revisions of prior
decrees additionally the numbering is
inconsistent between the books and films
for example decree number 68 in the
films is decree number 24 in the book
anyway let's get started number 1 any
student found in possession of a spell
check charmed quill will be severely
punished
number 9 any student found in possession
of sweets from unauthorized suppliers or
be expelled number 12
Hogwarts school will be subject to
informal scrutiny by an appointed
ministry member number 23 Dolores Jane
Umbridge has been appointed to the post
of Hogwarts High Inquisitor
this one matched the books
number 24 no music is to be played
during study hours number 25 broomsticks
may not be flown on school grounds
unless during authorized Quidditch
practice number 26 boys and girls are
not permitted to be within six inches of
each other
number twenty-nine extracurricular
activities are subject to review by the
high Inquisitor number thirty all
Weasley products will be banned
immediately number thirty-one boys and
girls are not permitted to be within
eight inches of each other number
thirty-five any items deemed not of
educational value are henceforth banned
number thirty-seven boys must be seen to
keep their hands on the outside of their
school capes aka don't put your hands in
your pockets number thirty-eight non
educational toys and games are banned
number thirty nine ones to be
confiscated from students cussing
recreational spells all magical objects
to be held by high Inquisitor until
further notice number 41 students may
not discuss the upsetting events of last
year anyone found doing so will be
punished number forty five proper dress
and decorum is to be maintained at all
times number forty-six any literature by
non wizards or half Brees is banned
forthwith number forty seven students
must consent to have their posts checked
for illegal contraband number forty
eight any complaints about Hogwarts or
its staff must be made in writing to the
High Inquisitor number forty nine all
quit matches are hereby canceled
broomsticks will be turned into the high
Inquisitor for safekeeping number 67
exploding bonbons are no longer
permitted to explode and in immediately
to ministry disposal unit number 68 all
student organizations societies teams
groups and clubs are henceforth
disbanded an organization society team
group or club is hereby defined as a
regular meeting of three or more
students permission to reform may be
sought from a high Inquisitor no student
organization Society team group or club
may exist without the knowledge and
approval of the high Inquisitor any
student found to have formed or to
belong to an organization Society team
group or class
that has not been approved by the high
Inquisitor will be expelled this is
number 24 in the books number 74 all
ours must be tagged to comply with our
post ministry censorship legislation
number 75 all pets other than ours are
confined to house common rooms and
dormitories number 76 any student found
in possession of the magazine the
Quibbler will be expelled this is number
27 in the books number 77
teachers are hereby banned from giving
students any information that is not
strictly related to the subjects that
they are paid to teach this is number 26
in the books number 81 red houses are
forbidden on the premises number 82 all
students will submit to questioning
about suspected illicit activities
number 98
those wishing to join the inquisitorial
squad for extra credit may sign up in
the high inquisitors office number 99
students are not permitted to change
their hair color eye color shoe size or
any other physical abnormality using
magic number 109 students performing
prohibited incantations will be subject
to severe punishment under section 28
number 119 Dolores Jane Umbridge has
replaced Albus Dumbledore as the head of
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry this is number 28 in the books
number 128 no student organization
Society team group or Club may exist
without the knowledge and approval of
the high Inquisitor number 129 students
must observe new restrictions regarding
library and common room access number
133 any authorized textbooks will be
confiscated immediately from the
offending student and 136 all students
will be cooperative and forthcoming with
information regarding suspicious
behavior or outlawed activities
and that's it for this video I hope you
guys enjoyed it did I miss any of the
decrees do you agree with any of the
decrees what rules would you put in
place let me know down in the comment
section below until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]